so big news related to a possible
criminal investigation of the trump
organization new york attorney general
leticia james announces that the
attorney general's office is teaming up
with the manhattan district attorney's
office run by
sci vance to combine efforts and that
the attorney general's
investigation is no longer just civil
but is also criminal in nature now the
manhattan district attorney's office was
already engaged in a criminal
investigation you might recall that the
grand jury subpoena went up to the
supreme court twice
where trump lost and the district
attorneys won and they should have
access to all of those records
but what is particularly interesting is
that the new york attorney general's
office is now teaming up with the
manhattan d.a
that basically doesn't happen that might
mean that this investigation is getting
a supercharge or just might mean that
the attorney general's office wants
some of the credit the new york ag tends
to announce more investigations than it
actually prosecutes so
we'll see whether we see anyone in court